hey chess friends national master james
cantona here with chess.com and today we
have game of the day with the white
pieces we have dragon and with the black
pieces we have leela chess zero what a
game let's see it okay so from the
beginning here dragon plays e4 nice best
buy test bobby fischer right e4 let's
see it g6 we have a modern defense so
this one can be already very swash
buckling and counter-attacking and very
very fun because you are giving up the
center very early d4 bishop g7 all
modern stuff modern lines in the modern
after bishop g7 knight to c3 and in c6
which is a different type of modern you
can see uh the gura needs a variations
and and etc of the modern it gets very
very difficult and also complex here for
both sides actually usually after c6 you
follow up with d5 and after f4 instead
of seeing the d5 option which uh will be
answered with e5 or knight to f3 queen
to b6 from leela zero already just
pressuring the d4 pawn easy knight f3
from dragon here defending and the
problem here with these in modern type
positions sometimes even in kings
indians um you will have the whole
center will be whites and that's a lot
of space and if you're playing a very
strong player it's very difficult to
play like that unless you know all the
correct pawn breaks meaning moves like
d5 f5 c5 and when to do them when it
benefit benefits you after knight two f3
there is d5 here and it looks like the
pawn is hanging but in fact it is
actually not after knight takes d5 you
can play queen to a5 check and then
after knight to c3 you have knight to c6
with pressure so i mean it is
it's hanging but it's not really hanging
because of the compensation that you'll
be getting back this is hanging bishop
d2 you have knight takes d4 happening
stuff like that it's not not the best
and if you play d5 you actually run into
like bishop takes c3s or knight before
it's followed by bishop's a c3 it's just
a whole sea of complications you're not
looking to do right this is why they
give you the pawn so after d5 there's e5
to shut it down and get even more space
after the e5 move bishop to g4 pinning
the knight and if bishop takes then the
queen is going to take on d4 so queen
takes f3 would be the move where you
have to damage your structure hence the
move bishop to e2 e6 locking the bishop
outside the pawn chain and not inside
like you would see in the kerokans
because in the french the bishop's on c8
in this type of position so it makes
sense lock the bishop outside the pawn
chain and b3 from dragging wanting to
move the bishop
maybe even playing at night a4 and after
knight h6 you do indeed see a knight a4
hitting the queen with maybe some bishop
a3 intentions queen of d8 and many of us
would be thinking of the bishop a3 move
of course a dragon can see much better
than we can so castles was the move for
dragon
and knight 2f5 getting the knight to the
center and this type of structure with
black the plan is very simple you need
to play c5 and f6 and sometimes even g5
weirdly enough because this is such a
strong mass of center that you get
squeezed a lot of times you know believe
it or not you can squeeze a lot because
the center is very strong and they have
a pawn on e5 it attacks sometimes are
just easy for white to do after h3
bishop takes a f3 and rook takes f3 so
now there might be some g4 and f5
eventually in here h5 has said you know
what you're not doing any of that we're
going to shut it down before it even
happens so white okay cool well we got
to figure out what we're going to do
here you know what let's just play uh
some bishop b2 bishop b2 seems right and
then after bishop to f8 we see c4 c4 is
pretty good c4 actually just get some
more space right as maybe some c takes
d5 rook to c1 maybe even grabbing more
space with c5 and playing b4 b5 like
you'll see in some london type positions
after the c4 move h4 this is a very
classical move that you'll see a lot
because they're putting the knight on g3
and actually just clamping down on this
square so if you ever play g4 up just
opposite or on croissant here and we're
just going to eat that one up and then
it's gone so after h4 there's bishop to
d3 attacking the knight and right here
you know modern players or person here
playing with the modern defense is
thinking you know i'm just fine here
right now i'm pretty good you know i
don't see any attack i don't see you
actually making this really be a problem
for me so black chose to take right here
on c4
leave the chat says i'll just take on c4
right maybe bully this pawn isolated
isolated pawn right so we can have a
target for maybe later in the end game
and then dragon says you know what i'm
going to take on that five right then
i'll take back on c4 but then well leela
zero read the red to play said okay cool
you're gonna do that i'm gonna play c3
right but now after c3 okay maybe i
could take this way this way or this way
but in fact dragon said i'm gonna do
this instead and in fact you know taking
is important because you have two pieces
hanging so you either take it and give
your piece back or move this piece and
the knight takes what dragon did was
actually say you know what you can have
the piece bishop takes e6
big engine move from a big engine like
dragon bishop takes e6 whoa and says
take it i dare you and he did because
the rook is hanging so i'm getting more
material here i'm getting more material
so what does he say you can have the
other piece he just sacked like two
pieces here
unbelievable in the way three four five
three four yeah he kind of stacked two
pieces there i mean because really he
got one back he did take one but then he
just sacked it and this one at the same
time and actually i mean this is not
over yet watch this bishop takes f7 king
takes we take back on b2 cool blacks up
a little piece right now one two three
four five white got four pieces one two
three four but we got some compensation
due to you know how this is going on
maybe some f5 in a way queen d5 of
course f5 did happen after g takes rook
takes king e8 and now watch this move
now of course you know we have one piece
right we or when we're down one piece
blacks leela chest zeros like i'm up one
piece but dragons here is like i'm down
one piece and when you're down a piece
the rule is
sack another one
said nobody
but but dragon did in this game
when you're down one piece sack another
one why not queen f1 after queen f1
queen takes d4
allowing queen takes b2
look at this position i'm down two
pieces for real now
right for real down two pieces now and
but if you look at the development if we
take stock of the position black might
be getting made it what do you mean made
it well you didn't develop yet and the
queen been out here in the wilderness
just taking everything that she wants
here and after queen takes b2 here's the
move rook to d1 is spot to get crazy
black goes queen c2 another queen move
just sabrina queen back to civilization
maybe and then after queen to c2 queen
f3 rerouting we don't have anything yet
you got to be careful we got to wait for
rook f7 we have to wait for it after
bishop b7 there's this e6 move which is
beautiful mandatory move and you have
believe it or not guys there's only one
move here to keep playing on is black
right if you try knight a6 i mean this
seems right
knight a6
seems like a move and then after 96
there's rook f8
and we great this is ridiculous rook f8
is a monstrous move are you kidding me
look at this
if bishop takes queen f7's mate
unbelievable and then if rook takes that
fa oh okay yeah can't check there but i
can check this way ouch and then mate
again
beautiful beautiful so you had to go
knight d7 because you had to block this
this whole thing so he takes d7 all
right king d8 rook f7 now we're only
down one piece you know king is in the
middle of the street i'll take this all
day and every day feeling great queen to
g6 and queen f2 a little bit of
rerouting queen g3 you think we by the
trade queens absolutely not queen f1
queen g6 and then a3 which is a sort of
a weighty move in a way it's very
interesting how sometimes all this is
going on and then they just stop to play
a3 and like a game where you sack two
pieces and like the whole world is like
shocked a3 and then a3 and rook b8 and
then queen f4 attacking the rook why not
get on that file queen g3 defending
through the queen defending my rook over
here queen f5 because we're not trading
queen e3 queen back to f1 a little
shuffle city see what happens queen g5
finally we got somewhere where we want
it to be right but we can't take this
usually yet in fact we just can't after
rook g8 boom rook e1
there we go
now we we have where we want this is
bishop's hanging we're also threatening
stuff like queen e e8 at the right
moment and if rick to g7 we can actually
play queen take c7 and after queen takes
c7 we can do rook e takes c7 and then
takes and takes and we're back in the
game
crushing it and we were already back in
the game like we're just crushing it so
queen g5 queen e2 root g8 a rookie one
king to c7 because he had to move out of
the way like this is real rook takes c7
let's say he moves it like bishop here
bishop here runs into queen e8 guys
queen e8 and then after rook takes
queenie a is made or you can do it with
the rook as well like
three rooks right just trolling here
trolling but rook takes c7 and then rook
b to d8 and rook to d1 at this point
okay white is still in the driver's seat
but it's not made anymore and it was it
really wasn't a mate of course
zero is going to defend like a machine
right a machine in baroque g7 rook takes
queen takes and queen e6 after queen e6
b6 check
now here watch this like this has became
more of an a more salvageable game for
black at least it seems like it after
king b7 b4 gaining some more space and
then here it goes queen g3 and after
this move this is over after takes takes
we have a 100
winning in game no matter how you look
at it with the white pieces it does take
accuracy and a lot of understanding your
end games and what you need to look for
but this is 100 a win so h6 g3 king to
g1 king c7 h4 gaining some space the
rook is tied down right rook takes d7 is
going to lose in many cases so h4 c5
takes and then h5 rick takes d7 again
loses because after i capture i'm going
to queen you can't stop me so c4 was
played trying to divert this rook so i
can take this pawn pretty nice h6 pass
pawns must be pushed a6
h7 c3 after c3 we just moved the rook to
c1 because now you can't take with the
rick anymore if you take with the king i
can do rook d1 check did take thin queen
like nasty
in-game tactics rick h8 rook takes c3
king takes d7 rook takes g3 we got the
pawns we're doing great here and
actually rook takes h7 is the move that
90 percent of us would play in fact
nine nine nine nine percent of people
would do rick takes eight seven here but
the end game is just losing we're i mean
we have two separate pawns here the king
has to be around to one of them and the
rick has to try to stop the other and
this is uh much harder than you think it
is um to draw but rook takes eight seven
so that didn't happen in fact king e7
from leela zero was like
e7 i guess uh that's one i'm not
familiar with okay rook g8 right and
then after king f7
you know we have to like
i mean like what happened here i don't
even understand what i'm looking at king
f7 now i looked at this with the lego
chess zero like engine part of chess.com
and right here actually back here they
were already giving it like plus one
plus 75 from this position let's just
zero saying this is already out so the
logic behind king f7
and not just taking the pawn on h7 is
like crazy like as a is it is a human
right you know clap it up for yourself
because we we would have played rook
takes h7 right but of course king f7 uh
happened and then after rick takes h8
the game is over i even went back and
checked just to make sure i had the
right pgn but i did and king f7 was the
move and after king f7 rook g8 i mean
this is just over this is checkmate
everywhere
checkmate everywhere but it was just
very strange to see king f7 there i was
like wait was that a typo is something
wrong what is wrong did it malfunction
what is going on right king of seven but
of course the game was already over
especially in little chess zero eyes
saying plus 75 before we even put the
rook to g8 so hopefully hopefully you
guys enjoyed today's game i'm national
master james canton third here with
chess.com and i'll see you guys on the
next video
[Music]
you